one of the young girls said can you
please ask him if he has a girlfriend
because we've been looking at him
tagging selena gomez on Instagram so
we've got to ask the question on behalf
of the girls do I have a girlfriend I
don't know I'm very much single that's
Niall Horan putting this straight kibosh
on rumors that he's dating Selena Gomez
no I'm very much single yeah you heard
him he's very much single can you ever I
just catch up with a female friend go to
dinner with that they're being 750,000
Daily Mail articles doesn't make a
difference if I am seeing someone if
they're just a friend of mine I'm going
out with them in the media it doesn't
make a difference whether I'm saying
them or not that's the most annoying
part isn't it really time to be friends
with a female so yeah safe to say he and
Selena are just friends but let's look
back at how this rumor started in the
first place because the signs were
definitely there
[Music]
in October Selina and Niall went to
dinner with a group of friends and yeah
his arm is around her okay that doesn't
really mean much but that's not all just
way shortly after they were being super
supportive of each other's new music
Selina posted this pic of Niall single
nice to meetcha to her Instagram story
urging her followers to download it and
when she posted a clip of her new song
lose you to love me he commented with a
bunch of hearts again that's not all
Niall also posted this shot to his
Instagram story posing in front of a
poster of Selena and writing hello there
Sal there were also reports that Selena
showed up tonight home a few weeks ago
and the weirdest part of all of this is
that this is not the first time these
two have been hit with romance rumors in
2012 reports surfaced that the duo is
getting cozy at Jena doin's 35th
birthday bash in LA and in 2015 fans
thought something was up again
especially after Niall said this during
carpool karaoke that's Barney Gomez
marry Selena Gomez good choice what
happened but at the time we went
straight to the source herself all the
fans want to know can we set the record
straight Niall are you guys dating no I
love him I always have I should also
mention Niall was previously linked to
Hailee Steinfeld and Selena and Haley
are good friends and I just don't see
salad breaking girl code like that
around here
with the greatest girls I learned from
my friends I throw from them they
encouraged me
I want the friends that will call me out
and really talk through with you and I
love that alright guys that is it for
today for all the latest on Salina Nile
and your other favorite celebs keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]